at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
a moment of courage in myanmar's deadly
demonstrations
a nun filmed pleading to protect
protesters says she was ready to die
also ahead nhs trusts accuse the
government of slashing away a promised
larger pay rise for staff
as more unions joined the row over the
suggested one percent increase
restore life-saving aid charities
condemn government cuts and donations to
yemen
as plans to slash aid to the world's
worst hit war zones and leaked in emails
an historic encounter pope francis meets
one of the most powerful figures in shia
islam
on the second day of the first papal
visit to iraq
and as the uk reckons with the cost of
covid
we hear from businesses which have been
busier than ever during lockdown
england's cricketers struggled to save
the fourth and final test against india
after another top order batting collapse
and there was a lot of dry weather
yesterday will it continue fine and
settle this weekend i'll have the
details for you later in the program
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the newspapers with the
entrepreneur kate hardcastle and
broadcaster dj and columnist neve
spencer
[Music]
a nun who knelt in front of armed
security forces in myanmar to stop them
firing on civilians has said she was
prepared to die
to save protesters lives in what's been
described as myanmar's tiananmen moment
sister nutong was filmed pleading with
police and soldiers
begging them not to fire on
demonstrators meanwhile protesters
returned to the streets of mandalay
overnight but demonstrations were
curtailed
when they heard security forces were
approaching
the city has been the scene of several
deaths as security forces try to crush
opposition
to the february the first coup that
overthrew the elected government
a u.n special envoy has called for
urgent security council action
saying around 50 peaceful protesters
have been killed in military crackdowns
this
week our southeast asia correspondent
siobhan robbins reports now on one
sister's
extraordinary bravery
[Music]
[Applause]
admit gina armed police are in pursuit
people are running for their lives
they fear a beating or worse
[Applause]
but during this battle a moment of
breathtaking courage
someone is kneeling in the road
sister anne rosa nutong has stepped
between police and protesters
a nun desperately pleading with officers
not to shoot
then
[Music]
the danger is real junta forces killed
18 people in myanmar on sunday
look there's a sister over there
stopping them a shocked reporter says
and being a 45 year old nun doesn't
guarantee
protections
[Music]
after the protest sister and rosa tended
to the injured
among them a journalist cornered and
beaten
and as the u.n talks about how to help
myanmar's finding its own heroes
those ready to step up for its people
an ordinary person doing the
extraordinary
against a terrifying military threat
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
also this morning nhs providers which
represents nhs trusts in england has
challenged the government over its one
percent pay rise offer for staff
claiming a larger figure was promised in
previous spending plans
the government is under pressure over
the controversial rise with a number of
unions
writing to the chancellor to express
their anger overnight
let's bring in our political
correspondent now rob powell um so rob
what what is the previous
um rise that that has been offered that
they're suggesting
so uh it was an assumption that was
basically published
in this document that was released about
a year after
um the long-term plan the nhs long-term
plan
um was announced by theresa may back in
2018
and there's a table basically within
this document which is an
implementation framework that's what it
uh says that
that it is that essentially says that
a 2.1 pay rise you can see there
would be assumed for the 2021-22
financial year and now that has led nhs
providers which basically represents nhs
trust so nhs trusts frontline care
settings like hospitals
they have said their deputy chief
executive safron cordray
has said that this document will mean
that some will think the government is
snatching
planned pay rises from the pockets of
deserving nhs staff
so they don't have to fund the extra
costs of covert 19
which the chancellor personally
committed he would meet now
of course the government has said that
we're in a different world
really since documents like this was
published that covert 19 has put
yes unprecedented stress on the nhs but
unprecedented stress on public finances
as well
and that is why 1 is all the government
can afford i think the risk though
is that pay rises
and pay offers like this and what they
do in terms of the morale in the
workforce could
dent the desire of people to apply for
jobs in the nhs in nursing
at a time when pressures on the nhs
are going to continue when they deal
with backlogs
from the covert pandemic also strike
action
whilst the nhs is attempting to recover
and deal with those backlogs
would not be good for the government
either i think there will be plenty
of people in westminster probably
privately at the moment
wondering uh why the government given it
had been in a good political position
with the vaccine rollout
and with the budget landing well
wondering why the government has chosen
to pick a fight like this
rob thank you all
businesses in england will now be able
to sign up for free covered rapid test
kits as part of the government's testing
program
companies including those with fewer
than 50 employees can register for
lateral flow kits for their workers
until the end of june
the test return results in under 30
minutes the health secretary says the
move is crucial
in helping businesses protect their
workplaces and
employees
the latest aircraft figures show that a
further 5947 people
have tested positive for the virus 236
have died within 28 days of testing
positive
and that brings the total number of
deaths to 124
261. 21.35 million first doses of a
vaccine
have now been administered
to iraq now where pope francis has been
meeting one of the most influential
figures in shia islam on the second day
of the first
papal visit to the country in the last
few minutes
pope francis has left the home of the
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani
after spending around an hour with him
in iraq's holy city of najaf
well our middle east correspondent mark
stone uh joins me now
from mosul um and mark just reflecting
on how significant
this visit actually is
it's extraordinary it really is i think
there was a genuine expectation that
the security situation in iraq and
the the dual threat of the coronavirus 2
would mean that the pope would need to
postpone the visit but but it's gone
ahead and clearly there's a
there's a controversy about that but he
was determined that it would
the core of this pope uh this pope's
outlook is interfaith dialogue and that
is why he has for so long wanted to come
to the middle east and to iraq where
religious polarization seems to be
pulling the country and indeed the
region apart i should explain that first
of all where we are now we're in mosul
iraq's second city
uh up in northern iraq until four years
ago this was the the capital of the
so-called islamic state
the caliphate in fact it was it was in
this mosque
that al-baghdadi the leader of the
islamic state declared his caliphate
back in 2014 he
stepped up to the pulpit of the then
intact mosque and and
said that from here to rome uh the the
islamic state would rule well rome has
now come
as people are saying here to baghdad and
to iraq
uh in the form of the pope the the
mosque is now destroyed
it is being rebuilt slowly as indeed is
the city the city around us
is is utterly destroyed it's empty as
well this morning
uh because of a curfew because of the
coronavirus the pope will be here
in this city tomorrow as the the final
day
of his tour but as you say he is at the
moment down in najaf he has just had the
most extraordinary
and deeply deeply symbolic meeting with
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani the
the most senior shia cleric in the in
the muslim world and a very very
influential figure right across the
muslim world
which explains why the pope was so keen
that these two men
should be seen meeting together they
talked together they prayed together for
around
around about an hour um this in history
will be seen as a
as a very very important moment two
years ago he was in cairo
where he met sunni leaders now he is
doing the same with with shiite leaders
this afternoon he will head to ore
the famous ecological site the
birthplace so it's
thought of abraham the patriarch of the
three monotheistic religions uh islam
christianity and judaism again bringing
together this interfaith
dialogue and then tomorrow he will come
up here which i think will be the most
human aspect of his trip the most
poignant part of his visit
where he will meet those people who
lived under the islamic state remember
one-third of iraq was controlled by the
islamic state until
just four years ago and the barbarism
that they that they um that people
endured here
was horrific we were speaking to a
family yesterday um
who broke down in tears as they recalled
their time under the islamic state you
can hear their story
later on on sky news he will meet people
like
like that family and he will pray with
them
as he calls for an end to extremism and
uh bringing together of different faiths
of interfaith dialogue
for the moment thank you more on that
throughout the course of the day
time now for a look at the morning's
other main stories and a sergeant in the
welsh guards has died after being
injured in a live
firing exercise in south west wales it
follows an incident at the castle martin
training area in pembrokeshire
it's believed the sergeant had served in
iraq and afghanistan
and was training ahead of a planned
deployment to iraq
in the summer downing street has spent
more than 2.6
million pounds on renovations in order
to hold televised news briefings
the makeover includes structural changes
equipment and internet infrastructure so
that nine downing street can host daily
news conferences
it comes as number 10 denied
conservative party funding
had been used to pay for refurbishments
to the prime minister's flat
above 11 downing street
nasa's mars rover has taken a short test
drive two weeks after touching down on
the red planet
pictures from perseverance show tracks
of where it has traveled within the
jazzero crater
where it's searching for signs of past
life the short journey lasted just over
half an hour
elite documents suggest the government
should cut aid spending to some of the
world's most
conflict-ridden countries by up to
two-thirds it comes as more than a
hundred charities condemn the uk's plan
to reduce aid to yemen
a move which drew cross-party criticism
this week
the chief executive of oxfam and one of
the signatories of the letter to the
prime minister
is danny shriskandaraja who joins me now
good morning to you
um before we we go into this letter and
what it's calling for
can you describe what the situation in
yemen is like at the moment
of the population are in need of
humanitarian assistance
we've had more than five years of brutal
um sorry i i wonder if i can just
uh ask you to start that answer again we
lost your sound
briefly momentarily so just really to to
explain the situation in yemen
sure thanks julian look yemen is a
country as the united nations says
is on the brink of famine a famine of of
levels we haven't seen for decades
two-thirds of the population are in need
of humanitarian assistance and
this entire country has been affected by
a brutal armed conflict that has left
people
starving homeless displaced uh it is
arguably the world's
worst humanitarian crisis that we're
seeing today
uh and you visited uh just over a year
ago i understand that what what did you
see on the ground
uh it was a desperate situation jillian
uh it's
you know i saw people who had been
displaced who'd been living in
in basically temporary camps for years
in a country that already was suffering
water shortages
uh was a country that was already
unstable has been really ripped apart by
conflict and
you know what made me proud was the aid
provided by britain
was saving lives allowing us to provide
family
water and food
he was on the verge of taking his life
before he was helped by their message
crisis service now shout
and danny i wonder if um you can
therefore explain
just what the significance is of
an aid being cut to yemen what will it
actually mean
look almost certainly thousands tens of
thousands of lives are going to be
lost as a result of this funding being
reduced the uk government has been you
know proudly leading the efforts to
to provide humanitarian assistance in
places like yemen
200 million pounds had been promised
that money is now being is going to be
slashed by
more than 60 percent and it's a betrayal
of not just the promises we made to the
world's poorest and most needy
it's a britain betrayal of british
values
it's an undermining of this government's
stated aim
to be global britain to provide this
sort of positive leadership
and arguably worst of all it's a
particularly callous decision because
this government has actually increased
the sales of
of british arms to saudi arabia which is
a party to the conflict
which we know is using some of those
british arms
to bomb indiscriminately in yemen
affecting
uh civilians and further driving people
into desperation and so this is almost
the worst possible news we could have
expected when it comes to the cuts to
the aid budget
what would you say to those who say
simply that we we can't afford to to
give
the sums that that previously we we did
and particularly because of the pandemic
that there just aren't the resources
available to help in the way that was
previously promised
so look i i recognize there's
unprecedented need here in this country
at the moment
but as the archbishop of canterbury said
recently about these cuts he said
it's important that we keep promises at
the worst of times
not just at the best of times and you
know there is a false economy between
choosing not to fund humanitarian
assistance in places like yemen
and and cuts elsewhere you know this
this little this money is not going to
make a big difference to
the united kingdom's uh uh debt or or of
fiscal budget uh situation and it's
desperately needed and we also know that
just as aid budgets are being cut
there's been increased expenditure in
fact
almost the same amount that's been cut
out of the aid budget is being
increased in the arms budget so that
britain can buy more bombs and bullets
and that just feels
wrong it's a betrayal of what are values
that uh that
the british people have um have central
to them
so what exactly are you calling for in
this letter to the prime minister
we would ask for uh humanitarian
assistance to be put at the heart
of britain's role in the world we would
like
aid budgets to be back to what was
legislatively
promised a few years ago you know what's
remarkable about britain is we were the
first country to commit into legislation
a 50-year-old promise that .7
of our gdp would be put to aid that was
an incredible commitment
it was a commitment on which almost
every single
member of the house of commons stood as
a manifesto pledge
on at the last election and it would be
a tragedy
if this government through executive
fiat
uh reduces that collective will of the
legislature
without putting it to putting it to
parliament you know that's another
implication here
that this is all being done uh from a
government
without going back to parliament to seek
approval on an
important change okay we await that
response
from parliament from the prime minister
on that letter
danny schriskanderager chief executive
oxen thank you very much for speaking to
us this morning
now a government uh spokesperson issued
this response to the open democracy
report suggesting aid
could be cut by as much as two-thirds to
some of the world's most
conflict-ridden countries the seismic
impact of epidemic on the uk economy has
forced us to take
tough but necessary decisions including
temporarily reducing the overall amount
we spend on aid we're still working
through what this means
for individual programs and decisions
have not yet been made
remain a world leading aid donor and we
will spend more than 10 billion pounds
this year to fight poverty
tackle climate change and improve global
health
time now for a look at the weather with
naz um
and is it going to leave us feeling blue
uh why because we're wearing blue
i think it's more likely we're going to
see bits of blue sky today rather than
blue rain
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning plenty of dry and bright
weather out there once again for today
now that's all thanks to high pressure
that's
uh right over the uk island uh at the
moment again
uh it is a chilly start out there this
morning though especially where we've
seen clearer skies overnight across some
western and
northeastern areas of scotland in
particular the east of scotland
temperatures are still below freezing
around minus five degrees celsius
in some spots there so it's frosty it's
chilly but it's mainly dry and bright
except across northwest scotland it's
cloudier less cold
some spells of rain there into this
afternoon we see little change on that
story really we may see a buildup of
cloud across some central southern
eastern areas and that may turn the
sunshine hazy at times under cloudier
zones a bit cooler but in the sunshine
and light winds it will feel mild
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
jackie's here with all the sport for us
what have you got coming up
oh i've got a lot of wickets not
necessarily the ones you want to see
anyway england's qriket is looking in
real trouble in the fourth and final
test against
india updates on the way as joey's side
lose early second innings wickets plus
there was a try of the season contender
in the pro 14 rugby last night as
munster tried to book their place in the
final
and that is not a bird watcher
but in fact golfer jason day will tell
you why he had to reach for a pair of
binoculars
during his round in florida
[Music]
margot was diagnosed with leukemia when
she was or in 2013
she was very very young and um they were
family friends
of of my family so we followed the story
very closely
and i was i was about nine at the time
and this was when
i uh was first exposed to the idea of
the stem cell register
and so this is when people who have uh
blood cancer
and the cancer is too aggressive to cure
with uh chemotherapy alone
or there are other blood disorders as
well such as thalassemia or sickle cell
disease where if it's a very serious
illness
and it's the only cure so um the
i yeah so i i found out about the stem
cell register that way
and i found out about the need for more
donors because only two percent of the
uk population
is on stem cell register and
unfortunately that means that
um not all the people who
join the stem cell register will be able
to find their life-saving match
and that is absolutely devastating
because it's the only cure it's their
only chance of survival
so that was what really inspired me to
write the book and obviously
it was a long process from when i was 90
years old then
uh writing the book when i was 15. i
think with young people yeah we are so
enthusiastic
about helping the world around us and
that's where you know the power of
the story comes into this because i
wrote the book to engage with a teenage
audience because i knew that if you
engaged with that audience
in the right way then they would
absolutely be be
you know uh excited
to join this register because really the
impact you have is incredible you save
somebody's life
and i don't or you can save somebody's
life if you're called and i think
not enough people recognize just how
important that
is to you know the person down the
street or somebody's best friend or
somebody's
parent who going to die if you don't
[Music]
register
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
jackie's here starting with the uh
cricket hotting up in more ways than one
oh it's all gone wrong oh well actually
if you're indian it's all gone right
uh if you're if you're an england fan
it's all gone very very wrong
lots and lots of wickets not the ones
that england wanted let's have a quick
look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
is this the future with its rush of air
crunch of gravel and electric wine
extremey sounds and looks like nothing
else
and is progressive enough and
competitive enough to hook
jensen button as a team owner button
who not so long ago seemed an electric
skeptic
if i'd said to you five years ago you'd
be racing in an electric series would
you have
laughed at me look at it it's it's so
cool
it's so exciting you know this is an
electric vehicle that has 550 horsepower
initially we ran in 60 power i was
thinking it's not very quick
and then we turn it up to 100 and wow
the series
five rounds will be held at global sites
relevant to climate change
from oil rich saudi arabia to a
worryingly ever greener greenland
but to maximize the messaging on global
warming
must the racing be red hot and like the
ecoscience
contents running in tandem easy to
follow
the format is going to be really short
races you know our attention span these
days is not great
i mean we're doing an interview here and
neither of us are on our phones which is
unusual
we're going to be racing in places
around the world that no one's really
ever
put a foot down on the sand or on the
dirt so for us it's an amazing
experience
xtremi enjoys relevance to the growing
electric road car market
but unlike formula e a series button
declined to
join avoids unfavorable comparisons with
f1 perhaps as a result it's attracted
three f1 world champion owners with nico
rosberg
and button's fellow britain sir lewis
hamilton also
signed up lewis hamilton has a team it's
button versus hamilton again in a sense
he won't want his
car to be beaten by button's car well
sebastian
loeb is in lewis hamilton's car so i
think lewis's team is pretty strong and
nico rosberg has a team
as well so um it's f1 world champions re
you know reuniting in terms of its
purpose
format and presentation extreme e
is different will it create a buzz
craig slato sky sports start now
i'm in i'm in
partnering to end racism in sport
music not me unconscious i was snoring i
was out cold that's a common thing
getting at times why
every time at 28 because inspiring i'm
not the same man i used to because
it punched out me
[Music]
[Applause]
you could be a sparring partner for the
day you can be a sparring partner for an
area champion in english something a
british champion
it gets a bit more interesting when you
spot the big names obviously when i
started becoming an aspiring partner for
you know the klitschko's the u6 and
the superstars from other countries
ultimately being flown over
you've been picked up in fancy cars
you've been taken to either a nice hotel
or
b somewhere that resembles a prison in
ukraine
one or the other and you're there and
you're there for a week there for two
weeks you're there for possibly three or
four
titan was good to me always got my
expenses a little bit extra sparred
klitschko
and you see now these are two totally
contrasting stories because
aspire klitschko flew to uh munich and
got picked up in the nicest car i've
ever been in
it was great the fella even opened the
car up put me in and shut the door down
it was great
oh my god i'm a superstar talking to
about a 10 bed mansion up in the arms it
was huge you'd
five star facilities and i got paid 1500
euros i was only there for four days
it was unbelievable it was just
unbelievable time in my life
i only sparred two rounds and i ran away
i never got here i remember thinking oh
my god next time i look in the hour
after this
performance you know our impression of
me eating and that mother boxing
contrast that with
uh ollie's under yousick took the
olympic training base
and i've never been to prison by the way
but um this is what i was in prison to
be like 200 years ago i remember waking
up at 4 00 am there was no deway no she
and it was about minus 10 it felt like i
was freezing so
didn't get back to sleep put on me put
about three jumpers on two pairs of
trousers just
started thinking why am i here i was
there for two weeks and on the thursdays
i was there we'd go to a spa where
youtube would stay
five star never seen anything better
anywhere nowhere in the world i've been
to a nicer place
when i'd leave and go back to the prison
not the prison sorry the word i was
staying
it was just i was so sad if you're
getting paid to spa
it ain't going to be easy because
they're not paying you for an holiday
clip it's good thank you
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
at 7 31 still to come on sky news
breakfast how women's careers have been
damaged
by the pandemic
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now ahead of international
women's day on monday new research has
revealed one in four women have
experienced a fall in income over the
past year
and more than half say their career and
their mental or physical well-being has
been damaged by the pandemic
investment director at fidelity
international micah curry has uh joins
us now from south london good morning
to you um tell us what your research
has found by way of experiences of of
women in particular during the pandemic
well what we found speaking to women is
that a year of disruption
caused by furlough lockdowns
child care home home schooling has had a
disproportionate impact on the finances
of women they've seen
a massive pay cut and that has had a
knock-on effect on their ability
to save and invest and of course the
mental strain
of juggling staying at home keeping a
foot in the door when it comes to your
career
and taking care of children now the
thing that really sticks out here is the
disproportionate
impact that this pandemic has had on
the financial well-being of women
and why has it affected women
so much more than men would you say
because there are many men out there who
would say that
you know their mental health um also
that the fact that they've been
out of work has affected them
financially also well it is really
interesting because typically during a
downturn or
a recession what you see is that the
impact is more pronounced
on men because men dominate sectors such
as construction and manufacturing
which is usually harder hit during a
recession or a downturn
during this time women tend to act as
stabilizers because they might take up
more employment increase their hours if
their partner
or husband loses their job but of course
with covet 19 all those typical trends
were turned on their head because of the
nature of the labor market because most
women
are employed in the service based sector
so
all of those things like hospitality
retail
hair salons airlines travel all of the
jobs that can't be done at
home or from home and all of those
customer facing
careers tend to have more women employed
and that's why over 19 has had that
really devastating impact on on many
women's careers and if you look at the
figures women
are one and a half times more likely to
have lost their job
quit their job or to have been
furloughed during this pandemic
and you found that this has had an
effect in terms of them sort of uh
reducing pension contributions and you
know making financial
investments that's right so um we know
that there's already a gender pension
gap
it's almost twice the size of the gender
pay gap and
um it's most pronounced for women
because women typically take a career
break to raise children
or to look after sick or elderly
relatives the knock on impact on their
pension pot
is very pronounced over time now with
the pandemic
seeing a lot of women taking those
career breaks
or having a pay cut or being put on
furloughed
on furlough that has an impact on how
much they've been able to save and of
course how much they've been able to put
into their pension pots
um so what is it that women can do to
redress this this imbalance what would
be your advice well i think the first
thing is that we need to
speak as one voice on this we need
government and industry to step
up we cannot allow uncertainty
uh the type of uncertainty caused by a
global pandemic to
unwind years of progress that's been
made
on gender equality equally women
why they might find themselves in a very
difficult and precarious situation need
to look at
investing so while we are diligent
savers
and we tend to actually save more than
men if you look at the figures
we don't tend to invest and of course
the stock market does come with a
with a higher degree of risk but over
the long term
investing in the stock market has
results in superior returns
okay good advice if you can invest
do so micah curry from investment
directorate at fidelity international
thank you
now while many businesses have been
struggling to stay afloat during the
pandemic there are some
which have been able to take advantage
of lockdown figures from the office for
national statistics show the number of
startups increased by almost a quarter
between october and december compared
with the year before
our reporter aisha zahid has the story
for this pasta delivery company the
pandemic brought on a surge in demand
and it was certainly welcome in a year
which has been detrimental for many
businesses
initially facing logistical problems
introduced by covert 19
it was quick to adapt we chose to
never stop our production we chose to
fulfill
all the orders and and therefore
we buckled down and we executed
our business has grown massively what
was previously the weekly volumes
now is daily volumes so over 2020
our business grew more than fivefold
this success story
isn't one that's been widely seen after
many businesses were pushed to the brink
2020 saw the largest gdp drop in history
but the uncertain climate hasn't stopped
new startups
like this sweets company based in
hertfordshire i left my job in january
just before covered ready to
get this up up and started and
then covered here and we just carried on
throughout we didn't let it stop us
it definitely slowed us down but we just
carried on it gave us the time
to essentially plan everything out so
where things may have been rushed
previously having that time to really
think through
they now plan to expand their brand
after striking deals with
major retailers this business is just
one of thousands to be set up in the
last year
and despite the challenges of covert 19
more than 400
000 startups launched in 2020 and with a
pandemic introducing a more flexible way
of working
experts say we're likely to see this
trend continue
lockdown restrictions have played a
major part in people deciding to take a
chance
i think a lot of people um have had the
opportunity to
um consider entrepreneurship for the
first time and really
pursue it i think a lot of businesses
have been set up that are compassion
projects
that of course is a challenge in making
sure that that is sustainable and
scalable while some business owners have
seen
positive effects from the pandemic many
now hope to see the damage to their
turnover reversed
aisha zahid sky news
as children begin to return to
classrooms in england on monday we'll
have a special program on sky news
we'll be hearing from students and
parents about their first day back at
school and they'll be putting their
questions
to a panel of experts that's covid and
the classroom back to school
at 8 30 p.m here on
monday with me
time now for the weather with nas is it
warming up
it was a bit frosty this morning um it
does look like temperatures
will be rising a bit next week but next
week
it's going to be unsettled with it as
well so actually
this weekend if you prefer the settle
conditions
is looking much better with mainly dry
and bright weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning get high pressures keeping
things fine and settled once again for
today and it's not looking too bad for
most places tomorrow
either so actually a fine weekend for
the vast majority of the uk and ireland
it
is a chilly start out there this morning
though we've had clear spells and
therefore frosty conditions first thing
perhaps less cold though across the
northwest of scotland
where there's a little bit of light rain
and cloudy skies there but elsewhere
it's a mainly dry start to the day
and it continues largely dry into this
afternoon as well with some good spells
of sunshine particularly across western
and northern areas i think
over central southern and eastern parts
of england though there will be a fair
amount of cloud in fact it is fairly
cloudy across these areas this morning
but it still will be bright at times
but under the cloudier zones it will be
a cool day but in the sunshine and with
the light winds it will feel mild
staying rather cloudy across northern
scotland there was some rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is sky news breakfast coming up
take a look at the newspapers with the
entrepreneur kate hardcastle and the
broadcaster dj and columnist
neve spencer
[Music]
it's all about numbers and boys we've
got some interesting ways of showing you
what's going on let's take a look at the
latest figures the most comprehensive
ever assessment latest analysis by sky
news suggests that's
never happened before totally
unprecedented when you look at this
and all the other data you come to one
[Music]
conclusion
it wasn't an easy decision to make um
but i think when my husband was
um faced with his difficulties and we
had to make a decision as to where
our lives were going it just seemed like
a
pretty easy decision at that time um
it's something i'd always been quite
passionate about but i think when you
fall into a career that you're quite
comfortable in and you're
getting okay getting on okay with you
you don't really think about sort of
moving
um until such significant things happen
in your life
i i have so much to be thankful for um
like i said if it wasn't for the nhs i
i wouldn't be here but the fact that um
my husband was also you know
as well as a family if it wasn't for the
nhs i don't think
any of us would be sort of leading the
the the lives that we are so um so
it was the it's the best way to be able
to give back and there has i mean
historically there's been shortages i
think for as long as we can remember
and again the route into getting into
nursing has has become a little bit
more diffic and difficult especially for
those that have already established in
other careers
however now um there is so many
different routes in um
just like myself i actually managed to
do an apprenticeship which meant that i
didn't even have the pressure the
financial pushes of having to
um start a new career i was actually
supported all the way
um so if anybody's actually considering
it i would say
um go for it there are so many
opportunities out there
and it's not even just nursing there's
so many different careers within the nhs
so even if you're
in i.t or if you're in engineering or if
there's
any other area that you may be
interested in let them electricians
everything everyone's needed so i would
definitely consider it
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
it'll be fairly mild in any sunny spells
today but on the whole it will be rather
cloudy and
cool again it's going to be mainly dry
though except across the north of
scotland where it'll be cloudy with
spells of rain and maybe some hill snow
over the northwest
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will be at a low level of
one to three again because of the mostly
fine and settled conditions
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
but that's now to take us through the
newspapers again the entrepreneur kate
hardcastle
and the broadcaster dj and columnist
neve spencer welcome back to you
both uh starting with the telegraph
first of all kate
and you've had a look at this story
really this road map out of
of lockdown and people potentially going
back to the office you wonder how
difficult that might be after so long
away from that
daily commute there is such a big
part to play in terms of us working in
those offices though because obviously
there's an immediate knock-on effect to
all of the businesses that the support
the places the coffee shops
the sandwich shops theaters for after
work activities so
there is a huge need for us to have some
life that goes back
to the idea of central locations and
working there
what i think the prime minister has said
is that he rejects the complete shift to
homework and he doesn't think it's going
to happen i think what we're
understanding what we're hearing from
people
is that actually they want balance
they're not saying they're not going to
return to the office
what they're saying is now they've
experienced working from home
and not having to have that grind of the
commute day in day out they've
lived life differently for some time
they want to reevaluate that
they want to make change so i think what
we're probably going to see in this next
normal is a period of adjustment as we
use technology to try and
manufacture the opportunity to work from
home more but we're also going to
i think need to out of a social
requirement out of a need to be with
other people
return carefully into these places of
work
neve to you the sun let's uh talk about
the
royals specifically uh megan and harry
and the sussex is apparently according
to the sun and some of the other papers
and
wanted to talk to oprah winfrey three
years ago
oh here we go every single paper just
looking for another
little piece that they can add to this
dramatic puzzle
so it turns out that apparently
megan was ready to speak up a very long
time ago
now we know that oprah was one of her
guests at the wedding
and it feels a little bit like she was
forming an alliance back then
did she really plot this conversation
three years ago in those early weeks
when she
was married to harry who knows we're
going to find out
more and more and more over this weekend
it's interesting that you say megan
rather than megan and harry and lots of
the papers also say
megan i mean that they are a couple
presumably harry would have been
in on that interview and and he's
involved in the decision-making process
but that seems to be negated in all of
the papers and it's just
put on on megan's shoulders isn't it
i know and it's also strange because
when when i was working with them
obviously at that time
they had just got married and we were
referring to them as their royal
highnesses
i mean i court seed um when i met her
and now
we're just referring to her as good old
megan things have changed
yeah yeah yeah the point that i was
making is that it's not just
about her that they are a couple but
many of the the papers
um do not reflect that onto the express
kate um and this story about an age
discrimination case
yes it's a kind of point to have a
conversation
and one that's really important with
monday being international women's day
and i think we've got this theme this
year for challenge for change
here is a lady that was in a role 72 and
she discovered that she was being paid
less
than a co-worker and she called that out
and in the abuse that came from the
conversation she was called an old woman
now i'm not for one second suggesting
that means we've also
got to get on our high horses women but
i'm not
alone when i understand that there is
ages and for men and women out there i'm
not prepared to have a huge percentage
of what i think going to be my golden
years if i'm lucky enough to get there
written off i'm talking about dolly
parton here i'm talking about tina
turner here
dolly parton who's just invested in
vaccines to try and help cure people
you can have the golden times of your
life at that
age so let's stop this ridiculous notion
that at a certain point we are anything
more than brilliantly experienced to be
able to deal with life
because i'm calling out ageism i've had
enough of it i want to see diversity
in our workplaces because of all types
of life being represented there
including people who've got more
experience than me because they've lived
longer
and evangelism doesn't seem to affect
men in quite yet thumbs up there doesn't
seem to
affect men in quite the same way does it
not at all my goodness me and the amount
of times there's a woman i mean i work
as a dj i work in a male dominated
industry as well as you know being on
on daytime radio essentially as a solo
female
a little bit unique and i constantly get
asked really inappropriate questions
like how old are you that's so rude
don't ask me my age
i'm not going to tell you my age not
even now that is very rude
very rude i can't imagine anyone being
that brazen
um but staying with with the highly
accomplished uh women of
uh senior years um you've had a look at
this story
in the i case and this is um the british
professor uh winning medal for the
oxford vaccine work that's been carried
out
so i'm gonna go for my second point in
this challenge for change
international women's day can we just
have a moment for professor
sarah gilbert let's hear that name let's
understand that name
i've got two daughters and a son i want
them to have role models
that i believe in as well as they
believe in she has just been given an
award
as a british vaccinologist who has been
at the forefront of leading
the development of the vaccine and at
speed she follows in line
with people like mercury who've also won
this rsa award
i mean we have got a challenge with stem
which is science technology engineering
and maths we've got a low representation
28 of the workforce they're only made up
by women we have to change this and
again we're only going to do this
collaboratively
i've worked with brilliant men and
brilliant women this isn't about a
competition this is about
building bridges and not thrones so
whilst we celebrate sarah gill but let's
make
sure we have investment and reassurance
and say her name more so a young person
female or male watching this can say
okay i can do that i'm interested in
that
our heroes can't just be people who look
good on glossy magazines
although she does look good as well
professor sarah gilbert uh there say the
name you're absolutely right
just time to talk about this uh last
story neve in the
eye and we know that schools in england
are returning on monday
hooray hooray hooray hooray i for one am
very very very pleased um but but this
story is talking about them struggling
um to get consent for the covid tests
well yes i mean there is such a huge
sense of relief just like you just said
but also as a parent a huge sense of
concern
how are our children going to stay safe
how are they going to test children and
it all seems to be
a little bit muddled much like
everything has been in terms of guidance
over the last 12 months
so in england secondary school pupils
will have to take three rapid tests
within the first two weeks they will
then
have to take further tests at home and
this whole regime is voluntary and the
main
difficulty that is being found at the
moment is parents
consent they're not filling in the forms
and it's all just
really all over the place it remains to
be seen how they're going to control
this and
mainly keep our children and our
teachers safe
absolutely most important that they're
kept safe caitlin thank you so much see
you in an hour's time